would you say humor is sophisticated and
comedy is juvenile
I I wouldn't is humor sophisticated in
comedy juvenile
um
I I I'm not sure that I would use I
would I would put those in those boxes I
think when we talk about humor we're
basically talking about written prose
um Robert benchley
um uh who you know Sandra Singh low who
else is you know writing comic pieces
um so in in that way because it's it's
it's verbal uh it's lit it's literally
literary you it's the writing
um I'm not sure I would say
sophisticated uh but it's it it's it
follows different rules and it follows
different dictates I think comedy comedy
is
designed to be
spoken and performed by human beings
and I think that's that's the big that's
the big difference is that comedy is is
actor-centric
um
in in drama the dramatic uh writer is
trying to make a point
um and uh he's he's got a theme that
he's trying to develop uh and and even
though there are characters in the drama
the important thing is that uh his
uh his
speeches uh reflect uh the The Writer's
point of view
um
and it's it's a a literary uh Centric
it's it's writer-centric
um but comedy as
as first performed 3500 Years Ago by the
Greeks is an actor-centric art it's made
to be
performed by
by people who
[Music]
acknowledge that there's in an imaginary
event happening but also acknowledge
that they're
being being seen performing an imaginary
event
back in the Greek Theater
Greek Theater Greek drama in Greek
comedy Greek tragedy and Greek comedy
were structured exactly the same
um they both had the uh Paradise engines
of the 50-man chorus they both had the
episodes where scenes were interspersed
with Carl Odes they all had the Exodus
but comedy Greek comedy had something
called the anabasas in which the 50-man
chorus came forward and talked directly
to the audience they broke the fourth
wall they said hey hey you that's a
pretty dress your one whatever you know
and and then they would go back as
though it never happened and continue on
to the audience there's there's lots of
Greek and Roman dramas in which the
characters in the drama acknowledge the
audience acknowledge that somebody's
watching them do this
so it's very actor-centric whereas
Hamlet might have a soliloquy right to
be or not to be but he's not saying so
what do you think you think I should be
or you think I should not be because if
he did that it would be a comedy
the act of breaking the fourth wall the
act of owning what you're doing owning
the imaginary uh events is
is a uh
Hallmark of comic performance I mean
there's a reason why
so why one person can get up and tell
jokes for two hours and that's
completely accepted
stand-up comedy
how many instances where somebody gets
up
and just tells us their life in a
dramatic way for two hours I mean there
are some solo plays but not as not as
ubiquitous it's group therapy yeah as as
yeah as uh yeah I've seen those I've
seen those off Broadway plays so what
was me story yeah
um
so so it's so so humor is written it's
literary but comedy is meant to be
performed it's not it's really not meant
to be read I mean you could read it you
have to read it you've written it
somebody reads it and says I want to
produce it because I think this should
be uh a um a play or should be a movie
it should be a TV series or even if they
don't they'll say this is really funny
you should work on our movie or our TV
series or or you should help work in
this theater because you you know this
this thing that you wrote which is meant
to be performed spoken lived through
lived through common characters comic
actors
um it's uh it's a actor-centric art and
so in that way it can be both
glorious but also it can be also
ridiculous it can be
um what was the what was the term you
used
oh um you you called uh humor
sophisticated and oh versus juvenile
yeah and and it could be juvenile or it
could be
revealing I mean there's there's a
wonderful moment
um in uh in Faulty Towers when you know
John Cleese playing basil faulty he's
the world's worst hotel guy you know
hotelier uh and he's everything's going
wrong for him and he just kind of looks
off to the side and says says what was
that that was your life that was your
life mate do I get another no I mean
it's just this moment of introspection
that we don't expect
from our juvenile Comic characters and
yet it's totally in place in a comedy
whereas you can watch you know
um
I can watch a a drama
and and enjoy it totally thoroughly
but never have never have a comedic
moment
whereas I can't think of a good
contemporary comedy that doesn't have
moments of uh moments of tragedy moments
of loss
how to surprise factor into comedy
hey okay that's good
um
because because the you're playing with
people's expectations so you can either
surprise them or you can
fulfill their expectations both work
both work you know a joke is based upon
the surprise ending you know the the
punch line
um uh waiter waiter there's a fly in My
Soup uh what is the uh what is the
flight doing uh what is that fly doing
in my soup I think it's the backstroke
you know you're not expecting I think
it's the backstroke because what is the
conventional thing the guy should say
the the guy should say
um well I'm sorry about that we'll give
you a new soup we certainly won't charge
you so when the guy says he literally
looks at the fly and he goes well I
think that's the backstroke that's a
surprise
surprising yet inevitable but also
there's the sense that
if you don't have any idea what's going
to happen that doesn't work for comedy
either
you have to have
some idea of what's going on the
audience has to have some idea of what's
going on to be able to enjoy
the predicament the characters are in
we'll go back to that the story about uh
um
Everybody Loves Raymond and he sees his
brother's girlfriend who the brother
thinks is the one eating a fly
so if we don't see her eat the fly and
then he's just stuck
you know he's Frozen for four minutes
and he turns and says she's not the one
how is that funny
so it's not just surprise it's also
expectation
and you're playing with the audience
expectation your uh you're having them
think one thing's gonna happen then you
then you do this the other thing or you
you're you you pull them into the
dilemma of the character and you wonder
what's going to happen and you're
delighted as you see the character try
and fail to solve the problem
or or like in the 40 year old virgin
when Steve Carell uh it's discovered at
his job that he's a Virgin uh we we know
that his co-workers are going to
definitely not let it go it's going to
become something actually that's a
surprise because he he they find out at
a poker game he goes home he stays up
all night he worries he says Ah it's
then he tries to talk himself into it's
going to be fine he goes to work and at
first this guy in the corners it oh
maybe I'm cool and then this guy just
says hi and he goes maybe maybe I've
dodged a bullet and then he sees Romney
Malco standing in front of a bank of
televisions showing a porn going we're
gonna get you laid this weekend and then
he realizes oh my God
so so it's one two three you know it's
okay it's okay it's not okay so that's
um that's part of of the expectation we
we're all waiting for it I guess oh I
guess it's not going to happen oh then
it does happen